it's been an eight-year wait but Freddy
Fazbear and his friends are finally
coming to the big screen whether you're
a series veteran or a newcomer to the
famous franchise he has everything you
need to know about the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie
all you have to do
is keep your eyes on the monitor the
Five Nights at Freddy's movie has been
in the works for a long long time it was
originally announced in 2015 with Warner
Brothers Distributing but by 2017 the
project had shifted over to Universal
and blumhouse even after the film found
a new home it still hit quite a few
snacks with multiple directors coming
and going an entire screenplay ended up
getting tossed when it didn't meet the
approval of game creator Scott cawthon
he wrote in a post on the gaming
platform's team I'm sticking to what
I've always said either the right movie
gets made or no movie gets made I hate
delaying a project that's already seen
so many delays but I have to go with my
instincts and what I think will be
exciting and interesting and what I
think the fan base will really want to
see fortunately blumhouse assembled a
quality team of filmmakers corfin gave
the go-ahead and now Freddie and friends
are ready to terrify poor Josh
Hutcherson
foreign
ERS at Freddy's movie won't have to wait
too long it comes out just in time for
Halloween hitting theaters and the
streaming site peacock simultaneously on
October 27 2023 it'll find itself up
against a serious Contender for the
crown of scariest October movie as it
will be competing against The Exorcist
the believer another universal blumhouse
joint
Five Nights at Freddy's went straight
too far from the games when it comes to
the plot and it seems to be
incorporating law from multiple
installments in the series the official
plot synopsis States the film follows a
troubled security guard as he begins
working at Freddy Fazbear's Pizza while
spending his first night on the job he
realizes the night shift of Freddy's
won't be so easy thus of course it's due
to the fact that the Chuck E Cheese
Style animatronics living in the
restaurant named Freddy foxy Chica and
Bonnie come to life at night and they
aren't exactly friendly there's no doubt
that poor Mike the security guard would
be experiencing the work week from Hell
there are ghost children possessing
giant robots
thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics we also
know that Vanessa a who first appeared
in Five Nights at Freddy's Help Wanted
will be portrayed by Elizabeth Leo the
hero of the first five nights at
Freddy's game is Mike Schmidt the
security guard who discovers that his
new nightly gig is no walk in the park
the first person perspective means that
we never to see what Mike looks like in
the games but in the film he'll have a
familiar face stepping into Mike's Shoes
which better be ready to run is Josh
Hutcherson best known for his turn as
Peter Mellark in The Hunger Games
franchise the actor has been busy in
recent years even if he hasn't been
appearing in huge mainstream hits he
starred in the Hulu series future man
did some Voice work in the Netflix
Ultraman series and appeared in movies
like burn and a Disaster Artist based on
the popularity of the games it's quite
possible that Five Knights will Propel
her to send back into the Limelight if
Freddy doesn't get him first he can also
expect to see Matthew Lillard as a
career counselor named Steve Raglan
Lillard is no stranger to Comedy tinged
horror as he's acted as stew in Scream
and a Shaggy in Scooby-Doo
fun game Sydney see we ask you a
question if you get it wrong oh yeah
you die well Steve Ragland isn't the
name that fans of the games will
recognize it's more than likely that his
true identity is William Afton the
creator of the animatronics the cast
will be rounded out by Elizabeth Leo
Piper Rubio cat Connor Sterling and Mary
Stewart Masterson you could also expect
hilarious Cameo from YouTube gamer Corey
Williams also known as Corey X Kenshin
where two
I don't always get the weirdos horror
Focus Film Studio blumhouse is producing
the Five Nights at Freddy's movie
adaptation and they've been involved
with the project since 2017. one by
producer extraordinaire Jason Blum
blumhouse is home to some other great
modern horror movies of recent years
such as get out Megan and Invisible Man
along with massive franchises like
Insidious The Purge and the Halloween
reboot Trilogy it's Halloween we've been
trick-or-treating are you alone there's
a creepy man in a white mask and he
keeps like trying to play hide and seek
with us the road to theaters has been a
long one with Blum telling IGN that it
took about seven years to find the right
structure for the movie he wanted to get
it just right in order to make the
game's Creator happy telling collider I
don't have the right to do anything
Scott corthyn doesn't like basically
Scott is kind of like the equivalent of
Final Cut and it's taken longer than I'd
hoped to get the right story in fact the
process took so long that some thought
Blum was wasting his time the producer
told IGN everyone said we can never get
this movie done including by the way
internally in my company I was made fun
of for pursuing this this thing that
could never happen and that always
lights a fire under me to say I bet I
can do this fortunately the folks of
plumhouse crack the code and finally
made something core thin approves of on
top of a killer script Blum has also
confirmed that the Jim Henson Creature
Shop developed the animatronics for the
film if there's any group of people who
know how to bring something creepy to
life it's a visual Wizards who created
monsters for Labyrinth The Dark Crystal
and all sorts of Muppet Productions
it took some searching but Five Nights
at Freddy's found the ideal director in
Emma tummy who previously directed The
Slow Burn folksy indie horror film The
Wind she's words with blumhouse before
specifically on two episodes of their
monthly holiday Centric Hulu series into
the dark called blood moon and delivered
Tommy told deadline stepping into the
rich terrifying world of Freddy's
alongside Scott cawthon blumhouse and
Jim Henson's Creature Shop is beyond
thrilling I cannot wait for audiences to
immerse themselves in the wild and
wonderful playground we are creating
Scott cawthon added I felt Emma had a
great understanding of the franchise and
really felt that she could craft
something that would please the fanbase
and keep people on the edge of their
seats Tammy and corthyn wrote the film
along with co-writer Seth cutterback and
they've evidently cooked up a great
screenplay that metcore Finn's
expectations of course Tommy wasn't the
first person to be involved as a
potential director when the film was
still set up at Warner Brothers in 2015
Gil Cannon was late to direct Canon
previously held the kids-centric horror
comedy Monster House and the dystopian
Adventure City of Ember after production
moved to blumhouse in 2017 Chris
Columbus was set to write and direct
until he left in 2021 that was a big
loss considering that Columbus is a
director behind the first two Harry
Potter films and home alone all previous
scripts attached to those directors have
been scrapped in favor of Tommy's new
direction for the film when Five Nights
at Freddy's gets ready to terrorize in
October 2023 it'll be scaring an
audience of all ages the film has been
rated PG-13 for strong violent content
bloody images and language it sounds
like it's going to be an intense PG-13
and it definitely sounds like some
characters are going to wind up
viciously murdered we're going to have
so much fun together of course there are
probably some people who are hoping for
a more R-rated Affair but this rating
really should be no surprise while they
have plenty of R-rated offerings
blumhouse also has a solid track record
of creating PG-13 horror if you take a
look at the Studio's most recent scary
offerings like Megan and Insidious the
red door or even some of their all-time
classics like split happy death day and
the original Insidious you'll see the
studio has produced some truly awesome
PG-13 horror flicks it seems that Five
Nights at Freddy's might just be the
perfect family outing for the Halloween
season assuming your family doesn't mind
seeing animatronics rip people apart
foreign